cher nicolas bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin sur rtl france
alors emmanuel macron et marine le pen à
1 semble tenir la corde pour un nouveau
duel en 2022
avec quels sont les premiers
enseignements de ce sondage
bonjour olivier mais aussi heureux bien
entendu on va parler ce matin de cuisine
de sondages politiques pour la recette
magique de la présidentielle 2022 rien
que ça vous me direz alors on est là par
les 1 67% des français anticipent ce
scénario vous l'avez dit olivier selon
ce sondage du 5 au 8 février de l'ifop
pour le figaro et surtout le chiffre
important c'est 70% des français
finalement qui ne sont pas favorables à
ce duel et je rajoute un derniers
chiffres de ce sondage 64% d'entre ces
français donc estime que le clivage
gauche droite ne veut plus dire grand
chose il est même dépassé ça c'est
extrêmement intéressant parce que ces
sondages les passionnants et j'écoutais
des commentateurs hier depuis les
sorties sondage quitté stupéfait
finalement ces commentateurs ils sont
stupéfaits parce qu'ils ont la même
grille de lecture politique et
médiatique depuis temps 30 ans alors que
la france et l'a profondément changé et
surtout surtout surtout depuis les gilet
jaune a beaucoup parlé sur votre antenne
finalement ce que ça représente olivier
c'est une tendance de fond et
rappelez-vous l'abstention record des
municipales lors des dernières élections
à plus de 60%
voilà et c'était le nom on est dès
maintenant aussi de la poussée écolo
voilà aux premiers points est ce que
nicolas cela veut dire que la droite et
la gauche ont vu le rectum électorat
siphonné par emmanuel macron alors ces
deux grandes parties olivier sincèrement
ils se sont sabordés tout seul on va
parler uniquement des socialistes et des
républicains avec deux grandes parties
historiques
alors il manuel ma peau gül avait planté
le décor en 2007 il
écoutez bien de progressistes
pro-européen et de l'autre côté là bas
au fond des nationalistes eurosceptiques
les méchants nationalistes
eurosceptiques pour moi je vais tempérer
un peu les propos d' emmanuel macron
c'est simplement le clivage des
souverainistes d'un côté et des
mondialistes finalement progressiste
alors pourquoi le ps et les républicains
finalement ils ont perdu ce sont avec
toi parce qu'ils se sont engagés dans la
mobilisation contre les français et
surtout il s'en sortit du cas de la
nation premier point parlons des
socialistes bon socialiste qui a eu le
plan de relance 80 82 tu as puis on a
abordé le tournant libéral de 83 sous
françois mitterrand lui même porté
parlant de plusieurs la mondialisation
lui rappelle 92 maastricht le traité de
maastricht l'oeuvre mitterandienne de la
construction européenne ça c'est
extrêmement intéressant et puis on a eu
le gouvernement jospin de 97 à 2002
finalement lui qui a entamé énormément
énormément de privatisation ayant
continué pour le socialiste pour ça il
faut expliquer pourquoi ils ont perdu
sociologiquement et idéologiquement
décision était favorable à tous les
traités européens
ça a été également le congrès de
versailles le traité de lisbonne est
spécialiste en beauté main dans la main
avec les républicains voilà donc
finalement l'épreuve pour socialiste il
en y est terrible de la mode
isation du capitalisme il ya eu une
idéologie fracture et finalement ils ont
perdu le peuple de gauche la classe
politique de gauche a perdu son peuple
de gauche
il ya eu finalement pour finir là-dessus
le naufrage idéologique de la gauche
rappelez-vous de ségolène royal en 2007
qui avait craquerez le bureau des idées
je me moque des républicains le
républicain c'est encore plus
intéressant parce qu'en fait emmanuel
macron il n'a pas tué la droite elle a
explosé tout seul la droite
rappelez-vous le point fort c'est
nicolas sarkozy il est traité de
lisbonne en 2000 qu'il a fait ratifier
en 2008 par le congrès de versailles et
y est assassiné avec ce traité de
lisbonne tout ce qui restait des valeurs
de la droite gaulliste nicolas sarkozy
qu il a été lui aussi l'artisan
finalement du naufrage de la droite
aussi bien aussi bien que révélateur de
la collision de la droite avec le
néolibéralisme et le marché il avait dit
en 2007 nicolas sarkozy avant son
élection je crois au libre échange et la
concurrence est maintenant les
républicains crient à lui et à diar on
ne veut pas d'un duel mâcon le pen
on se cherche un candidat naturel il
faut rassembler dans son temps mais en
fait ce camp-là ya plus de caen ça fait
30 ans que la république et non plus
deux camps et regarder tous les généraux
de la droite républicaine sont passés
sous l'étendard néolibérale d'emmanuel
macron ils partagent les mêmes desseins
il partage les mêmes idées finalement
est ce qu'elle est un peu d'ambition ils
sont partis au fmi à la bce ou à
bruxelles
donc finalement pour t'amuser ce point
là la droite s est extraite du peuple
depuis qu'elle a congédié sa fibre
gaulliste
rappelez vous du passage de l'ump feu de
rp rouergue où l'ump en 2002 bois et
finalement qu'à différents s'en tient de
jean françois copé bruno jacob du jacob
bruno le maire xavier bertrand dsk
françois hollande ou agnès
gachet en réalité il n'ya aucune
différence idéologique sur l'avenir de
la france et marine le pen dans tout ça
est qu'elle a ses chances selon vous en
alors aujourd'hui elle incarne une
nationalité relative mais ça
actuellement elle a une fonction
tribunitienne marine le pen bien entendu
mais elle pâtit grandement de son débat
de l'entre-deux-tours ap vous ce
naufrage fins et emmanuel macron a fait
des acteurs couteau dès le début alors
sa zone de confort et maintien marine le
pen finalement ça reste l'identité et
l'immigration les grands thèmes de
l'identité qui sont les grands thèmes du
fn qui sont maintenant les grands thèmes
du hérel mais marine le pen elle a un
gros un gros avantage qu'elle est très
confuse sur la politique économique et
sur la place de la france de l'avenir de
l'union européenne ça c'est extrêmement
1.1 point noir pour elle elle parle
beaucoup beaucoup d'identité marine le
pen mais elle ne sait pas comment
finalement appréhendé sa souveraineté et
ça c'est un vrai point de pour elle mais
c'est vrai il faut le dire qu'à cette
heure rien car actuellement tout du 27
france qui rochelle le système dans une
politique néolibérale et parce que et
voilà c'est un peu ce repositionnement
aujourd'hui à marine le pen
bonnaud on entend quelques noms comme ça
des rumeurs ces derniers jouaient ce qui
pourra y avoir d'ici mai 2022
une troisième personnalité pour venir
jouer les trouble-fêtes nicolas alors
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de politique
par marine le pen environ par les uns
qui correspondent à l'attendre des
français qui ont compris finalement que
l'état s'était désarmé depuis depuis au
moins 30 ans avec la complicité de ses
classe politique aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile à dire olivier on peut citer
nicolas dupont aignan a cité pour
exemple philippot qui s'en allait
starting blocks bien entendu mais malgré
que finalement ils font partie aussi la
guide classe politique ici on en a
plusieurs en et nicolas dupont aignan
qui devait rpm florian philippot qui est
un des cadres de marine le pen qui a
fondé le parti qu'il a restructuré
finalement ils pâtissent quelque part
aussi de se dégage isme de la politique
que les français ne veulent plus élisons
un électorat très très réduit finalement
ils font des cartons en commun sur les
réseaux sociaux sinon tous importants a
noté
mais aujourd'hui il est heureux qu'on me
baise on n'en sait absolument rien une
colonne de poignant voulait être
acceptée pour cent ou pour nous est-ce
que c'est le cas on ne sait pas et aussi
ce qu'il faut noter qu'à une guerre
d'égos terrible entre tous ces petits
candidats qui essaye de le brandir les
tells du fric site
et puis aussi vous le savez il se
murmurerait qu'il y ait qu eric zemmour
attendre et la suite des régionales
peut-être pour se présenter
voilà un peu mais une nouvelle tête
pourquoi pas est-ce-qu'il nouvelles
têtes aujourd'hui en politique un
politique française pourrait faire la
synthèse de la souveraineté finalement
et qui aura une véritable vision la
france vous savez le dernier grand homme
qui était là dessus c'était le général
de gaulle et pour l'instant on est un
peu démunis de ce côté en train de
souveraineté de vision et de conviction
que quelqu'un qui met un gant sonde est
le destin la france avant ce quart
politique sans qu'on l'attend pour
trouver malheureusement merci beaucoup
nicolas nicolas vidal qu'on retrouve
dans l'édito de la matinale je vous le
rappelle tous les jeudis matin